nous ne sommes pas encore le 11 mai
pourtant ils sont une vingtaine
d'enfants de 4 à 10 ans à être en cours
aujourd'hui l'école élémentaire de
case-pilote est l'une des cinq ouverte à
ce jour pour accueillir les enfants des
personnels soignants et la mairie ne
compte pas s'arrêter là
pourquoi pas ne pas reprendre d'abord ça
permet à tout le monde de se remettre
doucement et progressivement au travail
parce qu'on a estimé d'abord on était
prêt tu au plan sanitaire qu'on a
informé nos agents on a alors les gestes
barrière en dehors des récréations qui
ça sera très difficile sont respectées
maintenant
on pense que peut-être en septembre ça
sera pas réglé et qu'il faut bien
démarrer un jour thermomètre masques
gants sur blues visière gel désinfection
des locaux respect des procédures du
rectorat
même si de nombreux parents ne devraient
pas déposer leurs enfants la
municipalité se dit prête à accueillir
90 élèves dans un premier temps elle
peut compter pour cela sur une quinzaine
d'agents municipaux sur 20 c'était
normal qu'on ait cette application mais
au fond les agents se rendent compte
effectuer moi qu'il faut qu'on appelle
de travail ça fait un mois et demi que
bon voilà on a pas de cas travail part
donc pour elle aussi une vocation
travail à l'école donc salon monde doit
trouver effectivement leurs élèves
doivent retrouver leurs collègues et où
apprendre leurs activités l'école
maternelle et la cantine qui accueillera
les élèves par groupe de 50 seront
désinfectés la semaine prochaine face
aux risques sanitaires potentiels
le maire assure un enfant joue dans la
cour de récréation
en temps normal il tombe il est blessé
gravement ou pas le maire et responsable
donc quand on demande à être mère et je
pense que c'est comme ça que mes
collègues le font et le vois c'est qu'on
est prêt à assumer des responsabilités
vous avez des parents qui ont besoin
d'emmener les enfants à l'école parce
qu'ils ont besoin d'aller travailler
gagner leur vie et on ne vit pas de lire
du tort monsieur pour manger et boire il
faut minimum et ça il y en a pour qui
c'est capital donc il ya des gens qui ne
ce qu'ils n'ont pas d'échappatoire
si le parent veut envoyer son enfant à
l'école il a le droit de le vouloir et
la loi c'est que moins en tant que maire
je m'organise pour recevoir l'enfant
d'autres municipalités devraient ouvrir
certaines écoles ce devrait être le cas
de celle du saint-esprit avec l'école
mixte b à partir du 18 mai la ville de
fort-de-france et ses 52 écoles envisage
pour sa part une pré rentrée sans enfant
le 11 mai puis d ouverture éventuelle au
cas par cas dans le courant du mois
dans tous les cas tant que les parents
d'élèves ne seront pas rassurés les
effectifs accueillis devrait être
relativement réduit